في السودان قال مراسل الجزيره في الخرطوم
ان طائرات الحربيه للجيش قصفت اهدافا
للدعم السريع في منطقه بحر الشماليه
الخرطوم
وشهدت اعمده الدخان تتصاعد بالمنطقه بحر
بعد لحظات من القصف من جهه قال مصدر عسكري
بالجيش السوداني للجزيره ان قواته هاجمت
مواقع للدعم السريع في تقاطع القنطره بحله
كوكو شمال شرقي الخرطوم والحقت بها خسائر
في المعدات والارواح
وفي سياق متصل قال الجيش السوداني ان قوه
من حرس الحدود التابع لقوات الدعم السريع
انضمت الى صفوف الجيش في ولايه جنوب
دارفور امس الخميس ومتى الجيش صورا قال
انها الانضمام
2008 عسكريا بكامل عتادهم الى الفرقه
السادسه مشاه في مدينه نيالا غربيه البلاد
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء قال نطق باسم الجيش
السوداني نبيل عبد الله الجزيره ان ادعاء
الدعم السريعه السيطره على كل ولايه وسط
دارفور غير صحيح مؤكد ان قوات الدعم
موجوده في بعض المقر الحكوميه بالولايه
وكان قائد قوات الدعم السريع في ولايه وسط
دارفور غربيه السودان اللواء علي يعقوب
اعلن في وقت سابق سيطره قواته التامه على
الولايه
البعثه الامميه في السودان قد عبرت عن
قلقها البالغ ازاءه تاثيرات الخطيره
للقتال بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني على المدنيين في ولايه دارفور
وارستنكرت البعث في بيان التقارير التي
تشير الى منع المدنيين من المغادره نحو
المناطق الامنه الامر الذي ادى الى وقوع
ضحايا وفق البيان
واتهمت البعثه في بيانها قوات الدعم
السريع والبليشات المتحالفه معها
بالاستهداف العشوائيه للسكان البدريين
والمرافق العامه بغربيه ولايه دارفور
قالت منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه تابعه للامم
المتحده فوق ان سته ملايين شخص في السودان
على حافه المجاعه محذره من تفاقم ازمه
الغذاء واضافت المنظمه ان اكثر من 20
مليون شخص يعانون من انعدام الامن الغذائي
بشكل حاد وهو ما يعادل نحو 42 من السكان